[Music]
the falcon in the winter soldier has us
diving into captain america's history
sizing up everyone who's carried the
shield from steve rogers to john walker
and isaiah bradley to clark kent yeah
that clark kent
these are the many marvelous heroes who
have been called captain america
the one the only the original captain
america anyone watching this likely
already knows exactly who he is and how
his story unfolds
too small and weak to join the army
steve rogers joined the super soldier
program
in order to serve his country during
world war ii injected with dr erskine's
famous serum
the scrawny boy was suddenly transformed
into the absolute peak of human ability
steve joined the war against the nazis
often battling the red skull and hydra
in the comics
near the war's end however steve was
plunged into the arctic sea
while stopping a bombing run but the
super soldier serum kept him alive
causing him to spend decades frozen
beneath the ice years later steve was
eventually found and reanimated
in 1963's avengers issue 4 joining the
newly formed team
in their efforts to protect the world he
no longer recognized
the second person to become captain
america wasn't replacing steve rogers
but was rather the tragic victim of a
horrific attempt to reformulate the lost
super soldier serum
truth red white and black a seven issue
series published in 2003
explores the united states government's
attempt to try to reconstruct the serum
through trial and error
at the cost of human lives in an
unsettling reference to the horrific
tuskegee experiments
the united states launched a program to
experiment on 300 african-american
soldiers
in order to slowly reconstruct the lost
super soldier serum
when all was said and done only five had
survived and was successfully enhanced
of those five only isaiah bradley lasted
long enough to be sent on a suicide
mission
to destroy the nazi equivalent of the
super soldier program
isaiah stole a captain america uniform
and shield meant for steve rogers
and successfully completed the mission
but was arrested
imprisoned and experimented on once
again upon his return to the states
pledge allegiance to that my brother
played by carl lumbley in the falcon and
the winter soldier show
many fans met isaiah for the first time
when bucky and sam tracked him down in
baltimore
in the show's second episode audiences
also met his grandson
elijah who in the comics became the
superhero known as patriot
after a blood transfusion from his
grandfather made him a super soldier
the origin of captain america involved
some discrepancies that were only
cleared up through the invention of
william burnside
a most unusual take on the captain
america character we all now agree that
steve rogers went into the ice in 1945
but the character and bucky barnes still
appeared in several adventures during an
attempted revival in the 1950s
these stories were more or less ignored
until writer steve englehart
figured out a complicated way to make
them canonical writer steve engelhardt
introduced the idea that the 1950s
captain america
was yet another attempt to recreate the
serum and create a new patriotic super
soldier
in 1972's captain america issue 153
fans met historian william burnside who
was obsessed with rogers and discovered
a copy of erskine's secret formula
offering to give it to the us government
if they allowed him to fight in the
korean war as the new captain america
the government agreed and so burnside
changed his name
face and voice to exactly match steve
rogers but before the serum could be
administered
the korean war ended and the united
states lost interest entirely
undeterred this new steve rogers took
the formula anyway
and soon defeated a communist red skull
the formula was flawed however
and though it gave him greater strength
than his idol it also affected his mind
causing him to lose his sanity
the u.s put burnside in stasis until a
cure could be found
and he was eventually released from his
ageless prison in present day
where he fought the real steve rogers
for the mantle of captain america
over time steve rogers grew
disillusioned with increasing corruption
in the united states government
and denounced his former mantle and
shield becoming a new hero known as
nomad instead
during this time three different men
were tried and failed to take up the
mantle in his stead
in 1974's captain america issue 178
star baseball player robert russo tried
first but quickly gave up
after misjudging a swing over a wall and
breaking his arm
in the next issue street turf scar
turpin gave it a shot
and after receiving an extensive beating
while trying to stop a mugging
he never tried again neither men were
trusted with steve rogers indestructible
shield
the final replacement was a man named
roscoe simons
after the two previous failures roscoe
decided to try
proving himself capable enough in battle
to be trusted with roger's actual shield
he even began training for the role
under the tutelage of sam wilson
the falcon his ceramics were ultimately
short-lived however
in his first encounter with the red
skull in captain america issue 183
the villain immediately knew roscoe was
not the true captain america
and killed him prompting steve to once
again step forward
when steve rogers retired as captain
america yet again a new much more
successful replacement was chosen to
take on the mantle
in 1987's captain america issue 333
us army veteran john walker was just a
normal man before he was given powers
equivalent to the super soldier serum by
the power broker
though initially operating a super
patriot he welcomed the opportunity to
become the new captain america
and filled the role with gusto handed
cap's nigh indestructible shield
walker was by far the most physically
capable and successful replacement
up to this point but his hardline
stances and merciless execution of his
interpretation of the law
made him a far darker captain america
than steve had ever been
after he viciously tortured and murdered
a group of criminals who had killed his
parents
steve decided that walker was too
unstable to keep the role any longer
and stripped him of the shield and title
in 1989's captain america issue 351.
of course john walker joined the falcon
and winter soldier as a marvel cinematic
universe's first replacement captain
america
with a storyline that followed the bleak
broad strokes of his comic book
counterparts story
when steve rogers was assassinated in
2007's captain america issue 25
at the end of the comic book version of
civil war tony stark tried desperately
to find someone who could fill the void
steve left behind
in the third issue of fallen sun the
death of captain america
tony revealed that his first choice was
none other than clint barton
the heroic marksman better known as
hawkeye though a seemingly odd choice at
first glance
iron man eventually revealed that he
chose clint because he was one of the
only other people on the planet who
could actually handle cap's
indestructible shield
though reluctant at first clint went out
for one mission as the new captain
america
in honor of steve's memory but even
though he performed perfectly and
handled the shield with ease
that was the last time he ever did so
iron man had sent barton on a mission to
capture other heroes from steve's side
of the civil war
and once barton realized this he
immediately turned on iron man
and turned the mantle of captain america
down tony eventually found steve's
replacement in the last place he wanted
to look
captain america's original partner bucky
barnes the winter soldier
made famous by the movie of the same
name bucky's journey from world war
ii sidekick to secret russian super
assassin in the movies and comics both
steve helped him reject his brainwashing
and recapture his inner heroism
after steve's death bucky had no desire
to become the new captain america
but after the increased insistence of
many of his closest friends and allies
he finally took up the mantle in captain
america
issue 34. bucky initially used a gun
but eventually grew comfortable enough
with the shield and identity to fight
evil without it when steve rogers
eventually returned to life a few years
later
bucky gave his old friend back the
shield and then adopted the identity of
the winter soldier once again
a social worker in new york sam wilson
aka the falcon befriended steve after he
was freed from the ice and eventually
became his partner in crime fighting
starting with 1969's captain america
issue 117.
sam remained steve's staunch ally for
years and became so popular that captain
america's solo comic book series
was renamed captain america and the
falcon with issue 134
sam eventually joined the avengers and
fought alongside his friend all over the
world
later steve rogers was stripped of the
super soldier serum that gave him his
strength
in 2014's captain america issue 21
and subsequently transformed into the
scrawny weakling he had been in his
youth
rogers asked sam wilson to take up the
captain america mantle in his stead
and though reluctant at first he
ultimately accepted becoming the all-new
captain america in issue 25 adopting a
costume that kept the wings of his
falcon days
sam took to the skies to use his shield
to battle evil and injustice across the
country
when steve rogers was seemingly returned
to normal he insisted
that sam wilson keep the shield and the
two both remained captain america at the
same time
in 2016's captain america steve rogers
issue one however
rogers was revealed to be a secret agent
for none other than hydra
the very evil that he had fought for
almost his entire life
the sinister steve schemed for months
manipulating sam until he was so
disillusioned that he gave up being
captain america on his own
when he was finally ready steve led
hydra to victory
and conquered the entire country in the
event known as secret empire
thankfully his time and power proved
short lived sam wilson upon realizing
what steve had become
joined the underground resistance took
back the shield and became captain
america once again
the heroes eventually discovered that
hydra steve was from an alternate
timeline
and managed to recover the true steve
rogers once and for all
who defeated the hydra imposter after
the dust settled
sam wilson retired from the role of
captain america for good
returning the shield to the real steve
so that he could begin regaining the
nation's trust
though many heroes from marvel comics
vast catalogue of characters have done
the shield and mantle of captain america
the most unexpected person to do so
didn't belong to marvel at all
because it was superman in 1996 dc and
marvel comics agreed to one of their
rare
official crossover events in a series
titled marvel vs dc
the mini series was predicated on the
gimmick that fans would vote to decide
various match-ups
essentially determining the plot lines
the series eventually saw the two
companies heroes temporarily merged into
the maorgum universe in marvel vs dc
issue 3. the universe featured superhero
mashups like the combination of doctor
strange and dr fate dr strangevate
the batman and wolverine hybrid dark
claw and the superman and captain
america combo
known as super soldier still named clark
kent super soldier gained the powers of
superman in the 1940s when he received a
super soldier serum developed from the
cells of a deceased alien corpse
with his newfound strength a super
soldier took the fight to the nazis
and frequently battled with lex luthor
the leader of hydra
before he became trapped in ice steve
rogers was in love with a woman named
peggy carter
played on screen in the mcu by hayley
atwell a british secret agent
she was involved in the allies super
soldier program alongside dr erskine
and worked with steve in europe once he
became captain america
when steve woke up in the modern world
however he found that peggy was now an
old woman and their romance was one of
the many casualties of his last decades
in one alternate reality however things
didn't follow the same blueprint
2018's exiles issue 3 revealed a new
reality titled earth 86315
where the assassin that killed dr
erskine also killed steve rogers before
he could take the serum
encouraged by howard stark peggy carter
took the super soldier serum and became
captain america herself combined with
excellent combat and espionage skills
from her time as a spy
her new superhuman abilities were put to
devastating use against the axis powers
steven rogers one of the most bizarre
alternate captain americas
was created by jack kirby for 1967's
captain america
issue 194 and captain america's
bicential battles issue 1.
stephen rodgers was a captain in the
american revolutionary war
he disguised himself in an outfit
decorated like betsy russ's new flag
he fought alongside general george
washington until he was struck by a
cannonball
and finally killed in one of the final
battles of the war though some referred
to him as captain america
his descendant steve rogers would
eventually become the first individual
to truly carry that title during world
war ii though the gargantuan
coincidences needed to create this story
stretch the suspension of disbelief to
the breaking point
it's still a fun story that essentially
functions as a what if
where steve became cap a century and a
half before he traditionally does
by far the most recent addition to this
list is aaron fisher the captain america
of the railways
set to debut on june 2021 in united
states of captain america issue 1
by writer christopher cantwell and
artist dale eagles ham
aaron will be the first openly gay
captain america the series story will
follow john walker steve rogers bucky
barnes
and sam wilson as they seek steve's
missing shield drawing their search they
will apparently come across different
characters who have been impacted by the
symbol of captain america
one of whom will be aaron fisher
promotional materials show aaron
wielding a homemade approximation
of cap's costume along with the trashcan
lid painted like his famous shield
although he does not possess any of the
superhuman abilities of his idol
aaron will be a force for good who helps
runaways and homeless youth
along the city's many railway lines
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel superheroes are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one